an der straße zwischen den ortschaften
gottenheim und umkirch in baden
württemberg gibt es jetzt einen radweg
lange ersehnt lange geplant dafür hat
man die straße schmaler gemacht und eine
trasse für radfahrer auf rund drei
kilometern länge gebaut kosten rund
160.000 euro das ganze ist aber ziemlich
missglückt denn der weg ist mit 1 metern
70 viel zu eng geraten
die radler kommen kaum aneinander vorbei
wir haben wir mal einen radweg jetzt
sicher viel zu eng zu schmal und diese
katastrophe
also ich find bescheuert schon einen
beides mal ist das herausgekommen ist
das ist jetzt wie gesagt nur zeugnis sei
es in der nähe einer neue bundesstraße
gibt herrscht auf der bisherigen
landesstraße viel weniger verkehr
deshalb wird sie im auftrag des
regierungspräsidiums zu einer
gemeindestraße zurückgebaut zugleich
soll es endlich einen radweg zwischen
den gemeinden geben das ganze projekt
beruht allerdings auf planungen die
schon im jahre 1995 begonnen haben das
ergebnis ganz schön gestrig laut
verwaltungsvorschriften sollte ein
radweg 2020 mindestens zwei meter
fünfzig breit sein
besser sogar drei meter dazu kommt autos
fahren immer wieder auf den neuen
schotterstreifen zwischen straße und weg
und gefährden so die radler der es wird
jetzt gebaut für die zukunft und ist für
die zukunft nicht gerüstet das ist eine
fehlkonstruktion von a bis z
ich wunder mich wie so was passieren
kann wenn es 95 beschlossen wurde das
dann nicht 2020 oder 19 wenn es dann in
die in die umsetzung gegen nicht jemand
noch mal drüber schaut über den radweg
murks möchte man weder im rathaus
gottenheim noch im rathaus umkirch und
auch nicht im regierungspräsidium
freiburg mit uns sprechen man verweist
uns auf eine pressemitteilung des
regierungspräsidiums die aufteilung der
breiten der straße und des radwegs ist
mit den gemeinden gottenheim und umkirch
erarbeitet über ein
planänderungsverfahren abgestimmt und
baurechtlich gesichert worden
nur eben auf plänen aus den 90er jahren
basierend die radler müssen das nun
ausbaden
das ist ein witz hat hier so viel platz
neben der straße aber warum man dann mit
den radweg wenigstens mal 50 zentimeter
breiter bauen kann
im vorfeld darüber nachdenken bevor man
hinterher noch etwas nachbessern muss
und nachbessern wollen die ämter jetzt
zwischen straße und radweg soll
demnächst eine schutzplanke gebaut
werden und vielleicht wird der weg doch
noch verbreitert dann natürlich wieder
mit steuergeldern